hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna be
doing a Westworld season 3 episode 5
preview slash trailer breakdown video in
episode 4 we got some answers and the
trailer for episode 5 is more
substantial than the previous ones from
the season quick spoiler warning this
will contain spoilers for everything
that's happened in Westworld so far I'm
gonna speculate about this trailer break
it down scene by scene and talk about
things that we've seen in other
preseason trailers so if you're not
interested in that then you wouldn't be
interested in this video in episode 4 we
found out that all the pearls that have
been put into host bodies by Dolores
hail Martin Connells and this new leader
of the yakuza they're all just copies of
Dolores Dolores prime is still in her
own body and we'll learn more about how
these copies work as the season goes on
for the sake of simplicity I'm going to
refer to them as who they look like
instead of saying the Dolores that is in
the Martin host body I'm just gonna say
Martin I'm not exactly sure how I feel
about this reveal if you watch my
previous videos you know I kind of got
to that point of it being Dolores at
least in the one that was hailed because
that was the only thing that could
really feel like a twist I didn't think
that it would be all of them though and
it was a surprise but I'm not sure it
was a good surprise necessarily we'll
have to see how things play out I mean
on the one hand we have these other
characters that it would be nice to see
some of them come back but there is
still one purl that we don't know who it
is we assume that it's also a Dolores
copy but we haven't seen it put into a
body yet though so there's a possibility
that one of the characters from seasons
1 & 2 could be making a return now that
the season is half way over I'm
expecting that these stories will start
to intersect more the other thing that
the sowed for cleared up is that most of
everything we're seeing is happening
concurrently rather than there being
some serious timeline trickery that
we've been used to
we have seen some flashbacks but for the
most part everybody's operating in the
current timeline the trailer opens with
the flashback shot of the construction
of Rehoboam I think I mean this could be
the Soliman build that we saw from the
release date announcement trailer it's
not exactly clear if those
both the same machine or if the current
one is a new version of something that
they already had built we see a young
CEREC looking on the voice-over is CEREC
in the current timeline saying building
and god is not easy
there were people outliers who you
couldn't predict or control as long as
they're part of this there is no future
for us while he's talking we see more
images that are tied to the destruction
of Paris by the thermonuclear event we
got confirmation that this is what that
was in Episode four but not much more
besides the fact that this is CEREC and
his brother they grew up in Paris which
no longer exists the set up of these
shots is strange the group of people we
see off in the distance are fully decked
out in hazmat suits but it looks like
the explosion is happening right at this
moment it kind of makes me wonder
because there's a dead deer which you
think would be related to the explosion
but then CEREC and his brother are
standing there and they look unaffected
it doesn't necessarily all add up but
there's also a distinct possibility that
I'm reading too much into it I mean you
think a nuclear bomb going off it'd be
an act of war but I think it makes sense
for us to put that in the back of our
minds that we don't really know what's
going on here and hopefully we'll find
out sooner rather than later
either way we see the young CEREC
looking at the destruction at the same
time we hear his older self say there is
no future for us
the next shot is of him flying we see a
shot of him from behind looking like a
trillionaire in 2050 AIT's equivalent of
a private jet that cuts to a shot a
caleb walking down a hallway with his
rico app collaborators ashen giggles
sarah acts voiceover continues somewhere
in this group is an agitator who will
destroy the world I can't let that
happen
Caleb and the crew are on the screen
when he says agitator and that makes you
wonder if caleb is one of the outliers
that serac mentioned earlier we've seen
a longer shot of this from a previous
trailer Dolores is out front and Liam
jr. is behind him so they're leading him
somewhere as he says who will destroy
the world we see a shot of Dolores with
a serious look on her face it appears
she's looking at Caleb but we can't tell
for sure then we see CEREC riding
car when he says I can't let that happen
and I would guess that he's talking to
Maeve after they fixed her up after the
incident at the Yakuza distillery we
don't see maybe in this trailer but
after what we've seen in the last
episode we have to imagine that Ciroc
will continue to use her to try to get
to Delores after that things take an
interesting turn we hear Dolores say
it's time everyone woke up she says that
as we see Bernard and Martin looking up
at a giant monitor Liam jr. told Dolores
that he only had read access to the
outer layers of Rehoboam in episode 1 of
season 3 so this is probably that in
other words they can see a visualization
of what Rehoboam doing but they can't
actually control it after that we watch
as Liam tries to escape it looks like he
injects Kaleb in the neck with that dose
of the genre drug that his friend gave
him at the sex auction charity party it
looks like it knocks Kaleb out or at
least incapacitates him temporarily as
it looks like he falls to the ground and
the next shot we see of him he has a
much different expression on his face
the description of John Rowe was that it
was a digital psycho Pharma I read that
takes you straight to the silent era and
back once it hits your implant and your
bloodstream the silent era sounds to me
like it would be the time before
everyone gave themselves over to this
algorithmic determinism of insight and
Rehoboam but maybe there's more to it
because I'm not sure that in and of
itself would pass for a high and some of
these shots caleb does appear to be
boosted and that makes you think I mean
we don't know why Delores picked him in
the first place she picked him for a
reason there's something different about
him at one point he mentioned having his
implant turned off and we know he
surprised her in his decision not to
give her up to the people who were going
to kill him because they were trying to
collect the bounty from Rico this could
all just be tricky editing - because
there is a black and white scene which
could be an indication that that's when
he's actually under the influence of
genre we see a close-up of Dolores his
eye and she's wearing that augmented
contact lens we saw her put in in a
previous episode after that there's a
shot of a bomb going off inside the
insight building it's in one of the
upper
but not much more in the way of hints as
to what's happening with it that's
followed by some action sequences that
we've seen peppered throughout several
of the preseason trailers there's car
chases Caleb using an RPG type device to
blow up someone who's following him it
feels like all of this leads up to them
meeting back up with ash and giggles and
the scene where we see giggles asked who
is the killer referring to Delores in
the voiceover Bernard says have you ever
questioned what she's asking you to do
which sounds a lot like have you ever
questioned the nature of your reality it
gives us the impression as we see them
together that he might not be completely
on board with what she's asking him to
do ultimately I think that Caleb will be
a positive influence on Delores perhaps
bringing her back from wiping everybody
out or something to that extent but we
still have a lot to learn about what
Dolores is actually trying to accomplish
everything that she said about it so far
has been fairly vague she says she wants
to give people a chance with Caleb at
least there seems to be this idea that
the system decides that he's not going
to turn into anything so it reinforces
that path for him and thankfully this
trailer does seem to look like it's
going to give us more of an idea of
where caleb is operating from like what
he's trying to accomplish how working
with Dolores is affecting him and the
larger role he'll probably play in the
endgame there are a few quick flashes in
this final sequence there's what looks
like a detonation device on a motorbike
this is probably connected to an earlier
shot where we see a burning bike roll by
is a shot of Sirach walking away from a
meeting with someone important there's
military officers lining a red carpet
giving it a head of state kind of vibe
but you can't say for sure who he's
meeting with there's a shot of giggles
and ash with guns drawn and all the
emotions on a shirt seemed to be lit up
at the same time which is funny there's
an overhead shot of the beach we see
Caleb over Liam and the waves are sort
of crashing down we've seen this image
before and a lot of people jump to the
conclusion that it was Lee Sizemore that
was the person that caleb was leaning
over this is a lot clearer though and
it's easy to see that it's actually Liam
jr. there's a shot of Stubbs taking a
swing at Martin so we can expect those
two to get into an altercation there's a
shot of an unknown
character firing a gun at a moving
target which is probably connected to
all these car chases that we see and
then the trailer ends with Dolores
holding a flashlight or something
similar and she's looking at something
but of course we can't see what that is
so overall the trailer seems to be
focused on Sarek giving us more of an
idea of what he's trying to do and Kaleb
and how he fits into the bigger story we
don't see anything from the men in black
here or any shots of hail although I'm
guessing that that whole delos storyline
will still be in play all of the action
sequences are probably tied to the fact
that team Dolores has Liam and they're
also trying to take control of Rehoboam
that all feels pretty straightforward at
this point it's interesting because a
lot of the popular theories that have
been kicking around this idea of a
mirror world and part of the season
being depicted in what is essentially a
simulation I mean we don't see a lot of
anything here that kind of gives us that
feel the only thing in Episode four that
kind of even was in that area was the
made part of the story and the way that
she sort of had control over all the
computer systems as she was moving
around by the end of that revealing that
it was a Dolores purl and the character
that we knew as Musashi that kind of
changes the perspective of that but at
the same time I wouldn't rule it out
either
we know Rahul boom creates its
simulations and that's how it predicts
the future so that certainly exists the
mirror world certainly exists and
because it does there's a good chance
that it will play a part in what we see
unfold and with that I will leave it
there
I'm enjoying this season for the most
part and I'm excited to see where they
take us let me know in the comments what
you're excited about what you want to
see happen please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you're not already subscribed
thanks for watching I will talk to you
soon